[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the fan theory that
ruus hrid was a death heater since the
original release of Harry Potter and the
philosopher stone in
1997 theories based on the Wizarding
World of Harry Potter have abounded
there are theories out there that
Professor snake was a vampire and that
herione and Harry were actually siblings
some of these theories are more popular
and widespread than others such as the
idea that Neville Longbottom was
actually the chosen one Professor tror
spoke of in her prophecy about the
downfall of Lord Voldemort there are
also outlandish speculations that barely
deserve any discussion today however
I'll be taking you through a fan theory
that has gained some massive traction
online the idea that ruus Hagrid
was in fact a Death Eater the majority
of this theory has been presented by a
Reddit user by the name of wolf pH who
shared his theory on the subreddit fan
theories upon First Learning of this
Theory I must admit I was skeptical how
could the blundering yet lovable half
giant who rescued Harry from The desli
secretly be a dark wizard in direct
conflict with those he was supposed to
be allied with but after reading it I
must admit that theory is compelling and
filled with some incredibly plausible
evidence it is worth noting however that
the author of the theory has conceded
that much of the evidence against Hagrid
can likely be chalked up to plot holes
especially earlier on in the series but
it's still fascinating to see how it all
fits so well together to support the
idea that Hagrid could have actually
been a double agent and follower of Lord
Voldemort as another fan pointed out the
idea that this could be be true also
provides a really interesting balance to
seph Snape being a double agent for
Dumbledore in any case let's take a look
at some of the most valid points at
least in my opinion that support the
idea that hrid was a death heater from
this popular fan Theory to begin with
Hagrid a half giant working the grounds
of Hogwarts without a proper magical
education due to his expulsion from the
same school had many suspiciously high
ranking Associates and Friends he was a
trusted confident to Professor Albert
Dumbledore Headmaster of Hogwart School
of Witchcraft and Wizardry he was also
on a firstname basis with one of the
ministers for magic during Harry's
tenure at school Cornelius fudge not to
mention the numerous connections he had
through the Order of the Phoenix then of
course there was Harry the famous boy
who lived who throughout the series
seemed to feel forever indebted to
Hagrid due to his constant presence
during Monumental moments in Harry's
life such as retrieving him from Potter
Cottage after Voldemort killed his
parents and offering a listening ear
throughout his years at school certainly
much of this could be talked up to
Hagrid's perceived affable nature and
good timing but it does seem rather
suspicious that a lonly groundskeeper
who didn't finish school would have such
close ties with so many powerful witches
and wizards who opposed Voldemort unless
of course he had cultivated those ties
in an effort to serve the dark lord how
is it then you may ask that Hagrid would
have come into the service of Voldemort
and when well as presented by this fan
Theory it seems that he could have
become entangled with the dark lord as
early as the 1940s when he was a student
at Hogwarts for those who don't remember
it was Hagrid's fellow classmate Tom
Riddle who had gone to become Lord
Voldemort who framed Hagrid for
reopening the Chamber of Secrets at this
point in time we know that the two
wizards knew each other and even refer
to to one another by their first names
this is particularly worth noting as
Dumbledore shared with Harry that very
few people know that Lord Voldemort was
once called Tom Riddle but of course
Hagrid did so what if they were already
working together and Hagrid
intentionally took the fool for
reopening the Chamber of Secrets in
order to protect Tom knowing that he
could later clear his name and gain
Dumbledore's trust by proving he was
innocent from there Dumbledore would
have taken pity on H
taken him under his wing and given him
the ground keeper job at Hogwarts Hagrid
would have then been perfectly placed to
keep an eye on Dumbledore for Tom as the
Future Dark Lord went out into the world
to recruit more
followers further ingraining himself
into dumbledor in a circle Hagrid would
have then joined the Order of the
Phoenix and been able to keep Voldemort
informed of their biggest missions
including the effort to conceal the
Potter family's location in looking at
Hagrid's involvement in retrieving baby
Harry from Potter Cottage on that
fateful night of October 31st 1981 there
seem to be quite a few details that
don't add up to begin with how did
Hagrid know where to go to retrieve
Harry Potter Cottage had been magically
concealed by the fidelus charm meaning
Only The Secret Keeper fellow Death
Eater Peter wormtail Pettigrew could
have told Hagrid where Harry would be
even though Dumbledore knew the location
he couldn't have shared it with Hagrid
until Lily and James were dead as
Dumbledore was not the secret keeper and
yet Hagrid shows up on the scene almost
immediately after James and Lily were
murdered and before neighboring Muggles
were able to respond to what was
presumably not a small explosion Hagrid
also mentions that the only other wizard
he encountered at the scene was serious
black which suggests that Hagrid even
beat most other magical folks to the
scene he could have only managed to get
there before anyone else if he was
either nearby or told the location in
advance
neither of which can easily be accounted
for since he was living up at Hogwarts
Castle in the Scottish Highlands at the
time and because he didn't graduate from
school he was prohibited from using
magic never mind the fact that he
shouldn't have even known how to perform
more complicated magic that would have
allowed him to travel that fast take
apparating for example Apparition is
only taught to fifth years at Hogwarts
and as we've already established Hagrid
was expelled in his third year not to
mention that apparating requires a
Ministry issued license which of course
harrid wouldn't have had because he
wasn't allowed to practice magic at all
in addition to all of that he admits to
Harry years later that he was too heavy
to ride either a broom or a thol this
means one of two things wormtail shared
the location with him before the
Potter's deaths because they were both
death heaters or he was capable of much
more complex magic than he was letting
on now in regards to that last point
there are sever several pieces of
evidence to support this part of the
theory first of all he gets to The
Potter's House faster than he should
have been able to suggesting he's
capable of magic he technically
shouldn't be able to do then when he
comes to collect Harry from the remote
aisle on the boy's 11th birthday he
demonstrates twice that he's capable of
Performing Advanced magic to begin with
he tells Harry that he flew to the
island from the mainland as we've
already covered the T was too heavy to
fly a thestral or broom and there's no
evidence of something like a flying
motorbike or even another boat on the
tiny Rocky aisle that begs the question
of how did he fly there well without any
other reasonable explanation the
conclusion that we can draw here is that
he flew all on his own something we only
ever see two other Wizards do in the
series both of whom are incredibly
powerful Voldemort and Snape if Hagrid
was kicked out of school in only his
third year who else would he have
learned this rare and difficult skill
from if not the dark lord during this
initial encounter with Harry on the
small island hackd also used Advanced
Transfiguration magic to give Dudley a
pig's tail in this instance Hagrid was
not only able to perform this rather
difficult magic but he was able to do it
without verbally using an incantation a
practice which is known to make a spell
even harder to cast add to that the fact
that he cast this difficult spell
nonverbally with his broken wand that
had been snapped in half when he was
expelled from school and it seems to
support the idea that Hagrid was
actually quite an accomplished wizard
indeed not to mention the fact that in
performing that last spell on Dudley
Hagrid was not only blatantly breaking
the law in doing magic he was also
ignoring the international statute of
secrecy by performing magic in front of
Muggles almost the most disturbing
aspect of the scene though was how
little Hagrid seemed to care about what
he did to Dudley whose only crime at the
time was stealing some of Harry's
birthday cake and who later had to get
the tail surgically removed this seems
to suggest that Hagrid shared an open
hatred and distrust towards Muggles with
Voldemort as he never even attempted to
remove the tail or ensure that Dudley
was okay and while this court of action
was more than okay with Harry who had
been abused by Dudley and the dys for
years it's actually rather dark when you
think about how Hagrid's actions
basically just fulfilled the Revenge
fantasy of an 11-year-old
kind of seems like something only a dark
wizard would be into wouldn't you agree
in any case this interaction also
showcases the first of many examples of
Hagrid manipulating Harry into having an
unusually close relationship with him he
brought him his first ever birthday cake
physically disfigured his childhood
bully and then brought him to a magical
alley and bought him an owl which as it
turned out was a bright white owl that
as the theory points out was incredibly
easy to spot not a bad characteristic if
you're hoping to track all
Communications and whereabouts of
someone then later in the series when
Hagrid felt like he was less involved
with Harry and his friends he even went
so far as to act passive aggressively
towards these three teenagers until they
began to pay attention to him again
another manipulation to keep Harry close
in Harry's first year at Hogwarts we
also witness one of my favorite points
of the entire hagd wasita Theory the
fact that Hagrid basically hand
delivered Harry to Voldemort in the
Forbidden Forest despite the name of
these dark woods literally being the
Forbidden Forest Hagrid suggested chores
after dark in the woods as a form of
detention for Harry herione Neville and
Draco a group of untrained 11-year-old
witches and wizards after splitting the
group in two and sending Harry and Draco
off on their own they almost immediately
bumped into you guessed it Lord
Voldemort and if it wasn't for the
centur forenz who happened across the
scene Harry very likely could have died
right then and there it was also Hagrid
that piqued Harry's interest in the
philosopher stone that same year over
the months he let multiple things slip
to Harry and his friends about the stone
and where it was located in the castle
he even gave him a flute the key to
getting past the first layer of
protection for the stone Hagrid's
three-headed guard dog fluffy it also
seemed rather convenient that the last
few bits of information he gave Harry
Ron and Mye about the philosopher stone
before they ran off to go protect it was
at a time when Dumbledore was
conspicuously absent from the school the
next time that Hagrid so blatantly put
Harry's life in danger was in his fourth
year when he was selected as a champion
for the tri wizard tournament as the
theory states there were multiple times
that Hagrid pressured Harry into
sticking with the tasks convincing him
that he could win Hagrid even cheated to
help Harry overcome the challenges
throughout the tournament by doing
things like showing him the dragons and
the arena ahead of the first task he
even had a secret meeting with Professor
Madi Moody who was actually death heater
Bary Crouch Jr in Disguise the two were
seen conspiring which makes a lot less
sense if they weren't two Death Eaters
planning the downfall of Harry Potter
for why would an accomplished Aura and
Professor be meeting for a clandestine
drink with the school's gameskeeper at
the end of the tri with a tournament we
also left with the question of how in
Merlin's beard Voldemort got his
original wand back he was vanquished to
the shadows for over a decade and yet
upon his return to his body he somehow
had his old wand as the theory describes
the priori incantatum spell showcased
that the wand hadn't cast a spell since
his killing curses at Potter Cottage so
who'd been holding on to it for all
these years well considering Hagrid was
the first to arrive on the scene it's
quite possible that he took it for if
the Muggles had found it someone from
The Wizarding World would have
confiscated it and it either would have
been destroyed or kept under lockin key
at the ministry of magic if any Ministry
officials had found it the same outcome
likely would have occurred if Sirius
Black had picked it up the ministry
would have taken it from him when he was
arrested we know that Peter petre didn't
take it with him as he lived the next 10
years as a rat this leaves Hagrid and
since we know that as the groundskeeper
Hagrid would have had a hand in building
the maze for the final challenge of the
triy was a tournament and presumably he
was old Pals with wormtail he could have
used the port key to hand the wand over
to Peter who then gave it to Voldemort
once he had regained his body back all
before Harry and Cedric used the same
port key at the end of the task the next
opportunity that Hagrid had to put Harry
in danger was on the eve of his 17th
birthday during the battle of the seven
Potters Hagrid was conveniently
partnered with Harry and despite his M
size hagd the enormous half giant was
not hit even once by a stray spell all
of which were being cast to severely
injure or kill by other Death Eaters and
Voldemort himself this seems
particularly suspicious to me especially
considering that Harry was the Target
and Hagrid and Harry were riding
together even one of the Wizarding
world's most skilled auras mad Moody was
killed in the fry but not the enormous
magically uneducated Hagrid equally as
supicious was the choice that Hagrid
made to yell Harry's name out more than
10 times during a mission that was meant
to conceal Harry's identity almost as if
he was trying to get the death heater's
attention Hagrid then jumped out of the
flying motorbike abandoning Harry to
face vort alone and finally one of the
most solid pieces of evidence from his
fan theory that supports that Hagrid
could have been an agent of the dark
lord the fact that the Death Eaters and
Voldemort didn't immediately kill him
upon capturing him during the Battle of
Hogwarts in fact sparing Hagrid's life
in this scene went directly against what
the dark lord had ordered his followers
to do my instructions to my Death Eaters
have been perfectly clear capture Potter
kill his friends the more the better but
did not kill him so if Hagrid was indeed
Harry's friend wouldn't they have
immediately and gleefully murdered him
as soon as they caught him as we've
discussed he was not a small being and
the knowledge of his relation a ship
with Harry was well known the Death
Eaters who captured him would have known
right away that he was the half giant
friend of the boy who lived so if he
wasn't a devoted death heater himself
why wouldn't they have killed him on
sight Hagrid then unquestionably carried
Harry back towards the castle when
Voldemort ordered him to Harry believed
that he was under the influence of the
imperious curse but harid was able to
speak of his own accord suggesting that
he was not actually cursed while you may
have counterarguments or pieces of
evidence that contradict some of this
fan Theory I think that as a whole it is
quite an interesting one do I personally
think that rubius Hagrid was a death
heater No in fact I don't even think
Reddit user wolof pH thinks that but
it's fascinating how many scenes and
plot points support the idea that hrid
could have been one and with that we've
come to the end of another video what
did you think do you think Hagrid was a
death heater were you surprised by much
of this Theory actually made sense or do
you think it's totally unfounded please
share your thoughts in the comments
below and as always if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to the channel also be sure to
check out the content on Spotify as well
as extra content on my second Channel
Harry Potter Theory extra until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
[Music]
live